I just want to share with you what I
have been experiencing over the last
five years and having the great
privilege of traveling to many of the
poorest countries in the world this
scene is one I see all the time
everywhere and these young children are
looking at a smartphone and the
smartphone is having a huge impact in
even the poorest countries I said to my
team you know what I see is the rise of
aspirations all over the world in fact
it seems to me that there's a
convergence of aspirations and I asked a
team of economists actually look into
this you know is this true our
aspirations converging all around the
world so they looked at things like
Gallup polls about satisfaction in life
and what they learned was that if you
have access to the Internet your
satisfaction goes up but another thing
happens that's very important your
reference income the income to which you
compare your own also goes up now if
you're if the reference income of a
nation for example goes up 10% by
comparing themselves to the outside then
on average people's own incomes have to
grow up at least 5% to maintain the same
level of satisfaction but when you get
down into the lower percentiles of
income your income has to go up much
more if the reference income goes up 10%
something like 20% and so with this rise
of aspirations the fundamental question
is are we going to have a situation
where aspirations are linked to
opportunity and you get dynamism and
economic growth like that like that
which happened in the country I was born
in within Korea or our aspirations going
to meet frustration this is a real
concern because in between 2012 and 2015
terrorism incidents increased by 74% the
number of deaths from terrorism went up
150 percent right now two billion people
live in conditions of fragility conflict
violence and by 2030
more than 60% of the world's poor will
live in these situations of fragility
conflict and violence and so what do we
do about meeting these aspirations are
there new ways of thinking about how we
can rise to meet these aspirations
because if we don't I'm extremely
worried aspirations are rising as never
before because of access to the Internet
everyone knows how everyone else lives
has our ability to meet those
aspirations risen as well and just to
get at the details of this I want to
share with you my own personal story
this is not my mother but in the during
the Korean War my mother literally took
her own sister her younger sister on her
back and walked at least part of the way
to escape Seoul during the Korean War
now through a series of miracles my
mother and father both got scholarships
to go to New York City they actually met
in New York City and got married in New
York City my father too was a refugee at
the age of 19 he left his family in the
northern part of the country escaped
through the border and never saw his
family again now when they were married
and living in New York my father was a
waiter at Patricia Murphy's restaurant
their aspirations went up they
understood what it was like to live in a
place like New York City in the 1950s
well my brother was born and they came
back to Korea and I we had a what I
remember as kind of an idyllic life but
what was happening in Korea at that time
was the country was one of the poorest
in the world and there was political
upheaval there were demonstrations just
down the street from my house all the
time students are students protesting
against the military government and at
the time the aspirations of the World
Bank Group the organization I leave now
were extremely low for Korea their idea
was that Korea would find it difficult
without foreign aid to provide its
people was more than the bare
necessities of life so the situation is
Korea's in a tough position
my parents have seen what life is like
in the United States they got married
there my brother was born
there and they felt that in order to
give us an opportunity to reach their
aspirations for us we had to go and come
back to the United States now we came
back first we went to Dallas my father
did his dental degree all over again and
then we ended up moving to Iowa of all
places we grew up in Iowa and in Iowa we
went through the whole course I went to
I went to high school I went to college
and then one day a something they'll
never forget my father picked me up
after my sophomore year in college and
he was driving me home and he said Jim
what are your aspirations what do you
want to study what do you want to do and
I said dad my mother actually was a
philosopher and had filled us with ideas
about protest and social justice and I
said dad I'm going to study political
science and philosophy and I'm going to
become part of a political movement my
father the Korean dentist slowly pull
the car over to the side of the road he
looked back at me and said Jim you
finished your medical residency you can
study anything you want now
I've told this story to a mostly Asian
audience before nobody laughs did you
shake your head stick their foot
so tragically my father my father died
at a young age 30 years ago at the age
of 57 which happens to be how old I am
right now and when he died in the middle
of my medical and graduate said you see
I actually got around it by doing
medicine and anthropology
I studied both of them at in graduate
school but then right about that time I
met these two people Oh philia Dahl and
Paul Farmer and Paul and I were in the
same program we were studying medicine
and at the same time getting our PhD in
anthropology and we began to ask some
pretty fundamental questions for people
who have the great privilege of studying
medicine and anthropology I had come
from parents who are refugees Paul grew
up literally in a bus in a swamp in
Florida he liked to call himself white
trash and and so we had this opportunity
and we said what is it that we need to
do
given our ridiculously elaborate
education what is the nature of our
responsibility to the world and we
decided that we needed to start an
organization is called partners in
health and by the way there's a movie
made about that there's a movie that was
just a brilliant movie that made about
it called bending the arc but it
launched at Sundance this this past the
January Jeff Skoll is here just as the
one who who one of the ones who made it
happen and we began to think about what
it would take for us to actually have
our aspirations reach the level of some
of the poorest communities in the world
this is my very first visit to Haiti in
1988 and in 1988 we we elaborated a sort
of mission statement which is we are
going to make the preferential option
for the poor in health now it took us a
long time and we were graduate students
in anthropology we were eating up you
know one side of marks and down the
other Habra masa Fernand Brazil we were
eating everything and we had to come to
a conclusion of how are we going to
structure our work so Oh for the P we
called it a preferential option for the
poor the most important thing about a
preferential option for the poor is what
it's not it's not a preference or option
for your
own sense of heroism it's not a
preferential option for your own idea
about how to lift the port out of
poverty if not a preferential option for
your own organization and the hardest of
all it's not a preferential option for
your poor it's a preferential option for
the poor so what do you do well Haiti we
started building everyone told us the
cost-effective thing it's just focused
on vaccinations and maybe a feeding
program but what the Haitians wanted was
a hospital they wanted schools they
wanted to provide their children with
the opportunities that they'd been
hearing about from others relatives for
example who'd gone to the United States
they wanted the same kinds of
opportunities as my parents did I and so
that's what we did we build hospitals we
provided education and we did everything
we could to try to give them
opportunities now my experience really
became intense at Partners in Health in
this community cutter Bayou in the
northern slums of Lima Peru and in this
community we started off by really just
going to people's homes and talking to
people and we discovered an outbreak an
epidemic of multi drug-resistant
tuberculosis this is milk yogurt milk
yeah this is was a patient at that time
is about 18 years old
and he had a very difficult form of
drug-resistant tuberculosis all of the
Guru's in the world the global health
gurus said it is not cost effective to
treat drug-resistant tuberculosis it's
too complicated it's too expensive you
just can't do it it can't be done and in
addition they were getting angry at us
because the implication was if it could
be done we would have done it who do you
think you are and the people that we
fought with were the World Health
Organization and and probably the the
organization we fought with most was the
World Bank Group now we did everything
we could to convince Melquiades
to take his medicines because it's
really hard and not once during the time
of treatment that Melquiades family ever
say hey you know mal Theotis is just not
affective why don't you go on and treat
somebody else I hadn't seen Melquiades
for about ten years and when we had our
annual meetings in Lima Peru a couple of
years ago the film makers found him and
here is us getting together he's become
a bit of a media star because he goes to
the fill openings and he knows how to he
knows how to work an audience now but as
soon as we won we did win we won the
argument you should treat multi
drug-resistant tuberculosis we heard the
same arguments in the early 2000s about
HIV all of the leading global health
people in the world said it is
impossible to treat HIV in poor
countries too expensive too complicated
you can't do it
compared to drug-resistant TB treatment
it's actually easier and we were seeing
patients like this just of June Joseph's
June also never mentioned that he was
not cost-effective a few months of
medicines and this is what he looked
like which we call that the Lazarus
effect of HIV treatment joseline came to
us looking like this this is what she
looked like a few months later right now
our argument our battle we thought was
with the organizations that kept saying
it's not cost-effective we were saying
no preferential option for the poor
requires us to raise our aspirations to
meet those are the poor for themselves
and they said well that's a nice thought
but it's just not cost-effective so in
the in the nerdy way that we we have we
have operated partners now we wrote a
book against basically the World Bank it
says that because the World Bank is
focus so much on just economic growth
and said that governments have to have
to shrink their budgets and reduce
expenditures in health education and
Social Welfare we thought that was
fundamentally wrong and we argued with
the World Bank and then a crazy thing
happened President Obama nominated me to
be president of the World Bank
now when I went to do the vetting
process with President Obama's team they
had a copy of dying for growth and they
had read every page and I said okay
that's it right you guys are going to
drop me because oh no no it's okay
oh and he I was nominated and I walked
through the door of the World Bank Group
on July of 2012 and that statement on
the wall our dream is a world free of
poverty a few months after that we
actually turned it into a goal and
extreme poverty by 2030 who shared
prosperity that's what we do now at the
World Bank Group and I feel like I have
brought the preferential option for the
poor to the World Bank Group but this is
Ted and so I want to share with you some
concerns and then make a proposal the
fourth Industrial Revolution came out
you guys know so much better than I do
but here's the thing that concerns me
what we hear about is job loss you've
all heard that our own data suggests to
us that two-thirds of all jobs currently
existing jobs in developing countries
will be lost because of automation now
you've got to make up for those jobs but
now one of the ways to make up for those
jobs is to turn community health workers
into a formal labor force that's what we
want to do we think we think the numbers
will work out that as health outcomes
get better and as people have formal
work we're going to be able to train
them with the soft skills training that
you add to it to become workers that
that will have a huge impact and that
may be the one area that grows the most
but here's the other thing that bothers
me right now it seems pretty clear to me
that the jobs of the future will be more
digitally demanding and there isn't
there is a crisis in childhood stunting
so this is these are of photos from
Charles Nelson who share these with us
from Harvard Medical School and what
these photos show on the one side on the
left side is a three year three months
old who has been stunted not adequate
nutrition not adequate stimulation and
on the other side of course is a normal
child and the normal child has all these
neuronal connections now the neuronal
can
actions are important because that is
the definition of human capital now we
know that we can reduce these rates we
can reduce these rates of childhood
stunting quickly but if we don't India
for example with 38% childhood stunting
how are they going to compete in the
economy of the future if 40% of their
future workers cannot achieve
educationally and then certainly we
worry about achieving economically in a
way that will help the country as a
whole grow now how what are we going to
do 78 trillion is the amount is the size
of the global economy eight point five
five trillion are sitting in negative
interest rate bonds that means that you
give the German of central bank your
money and then you pay them to keep your
money that's a negative interest rate
but twenty four point four trillion in
very low earning government bonds and
eight trillion literally sitting in
within the hands of rich people under
their very large mattresses what we are
trying to do is now use our own tools
and just to get nerdy for a second we're
talking about first loss risk debt
instruments we're talking about
de-risking blended finance we're talking
about political risk insurance credit
enhancement all these things that I've
now learned at the World Bank Group that
rich people use every single day to make
themselves richer but we haven't used
aggressively enough on behalf of the
poor to bring this capital in
so does this work can you actually bring
private sector players into a into a
country and really make things work well
we've done it a couple of times
this is Zambia scaling solar it's a box
set solution from the World Bank where
we come in and we do all the things you
need to attract private sector investors
in in this case Zambia went from having
a cost of electricity at 25 cents a
kilowatt hour and by just doing simple
things doing the auction of changing
some policies we were able to bring the
cost down lowest bid 25 cents a kilowatt
hour floor for Zambia the lowest bid was
four point seven cents a kilowatt hour
it's possible but here's my proposal for
you this is from a group called zipline
cool company and they literally are
rocket scientists they've figured out
how to use drones in Rwanda this is me
launching a drone in Rwanda that
delivers blood anywhere in the country
in less than an hour so we save lives
this program saved lives this program
made money for zipline and this program
saved huge amounts of money for Wanda
that's what we need and we need that
from all of you I'm asking you carve out
a little bit of time in your brain to
think about the technologies that you
work on the companies that you start the
design that you do think a little bit
and work with us to see if we can come
up with these kinds of extraordinary
win-win solutions I'm going to leave you
with one final story I was in Tanzania
and I was in a classroom this is me with
a classroom eleventh of eleven year olds
and I asked him as I always do what do
you want to be when you grow up to raise
their hand and said I want to be
President the World Bank
and just like you my own team and their
teachers left but then I stopped them I
said look I want to tell your story when
I was born in South Korea this is what
it looked like this is where I came from
and when I was 3 years old
in preschool I don't think that George
David woods the president of the World
Bank if he had visited Korea on that day
and come to my classroom that he would
have thought that the future president
of World Bank is sitting in that
classroom don't let anyone ever tell you
that you cannot be President of the
World Bank now thank you let me leave
you with one thought I came from a
country that was the poorest in the
world I'm president of the World Bank I
cannot and I will not pull up the ladder
behind me this is urgent
aspirations are going up everywhere
aspirations are going up you folks in
this room work with us we know that we
can find those zip like types type
solutions and help the poor leapfrog
into a better world but it won't happen
until we work together the future you
and especially for your children the
future you will depend on how much care
and compassion we bring to ensuring that
the future us provides equality of
opportunity for every child in the world
thank you very much
you'd almost think people are surprised
to hear a talk like this from the
president of the World Bank like kind of
cook I just encourage you to even be a
little more specific on your proposal
there's many investors entrepreneurs in
this room what what
how are you partner with them what's
that 180 or five can I get nerdy for
just a second absolutely specific so
here's what we did you know insurance
companies never invest in developing
country infrastructure for example
because they they can't take the risk
they're you know they're holding money
for people who pay for insurance so what
we did was the Swedish International
Development Association gave us a little
bit of money we went out and raised a
little bit more money a hundred million
and we took first loss meaning if this
thing goes bad ten percent of the loss
will just eat and the rest of you will
be safe and that created a 90% chunk
tranche that was triple B investment
grade so the insurance companies
invested so for us what we what we're
doing is is taking our public money and
using it to D risk specific instruments
to bring people in off sizes all of you
who are sitting on trillions of dollars
of cash come to us right and you know
what you'll specifically looking for our
investment proposals that that create
employment in that absolutely that's the
reason so these will be for example in
infrastructure that brings energy you
know builds roads builds bridges build
supports these kinds of things are
necessary to create jobs but also what
we're saying is you may think that the
technology you're working on or the
business that you're working on may not
have applications in the developing
world but look at your line right and
that zip line thing didn't happen just
because of the quality of the technology
it was because they engage with the
rwandan s-- early and used artificial
intelligence one thing you know rwanda
has great broadband but the these things
fly completely on their own how much so
we will help you do that we will make
the introductions will even provide
financing we will help you do that how
much capital is the World Bank willing
to deploy to back those kinds of fish
you're always getting me to try to do
something like they're trying to get you
a couple so here here's what we're going
to do right so we have a twenty five
billion a year there
investing in four countries and as we in
the poorest countries and as we invest
over the next three years 25 billion a
year we have got to think with you about
how to use that money more effectively
so I can't give you a specific number
expensive the quality of the ideas so
bring us your ideas and I don't think
that financing is going to be the
problem all right
you head up in the man himself Jim thank
you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]